in the remote shader valley the heads of
people have lived like this for 10,000
years they still depend on the forest
for hunting meats in gathering fruits
and even whistling to birds which lead
them to honey but today their land is
under threat and to protect it they're
turning to modern technology nokia sana
we hate it we don't like to see the
trees cut down like this Ezekiel filippo
is one of the Hudson's forest guards who
patrolled the area looking for signs of
damage his team uses GPS satellite
tracking to collect evidence of the
destruction Trumbo comically taku taku
we use tools to record where we have
been on patrol and we take pictures if
we come across an area where someone has
destroyed trees we take a picture on the
GPS device and it records the location
the problem is the competition for this
land other tribes need space for farming
and cattle grazing and in places that
means the natural habitat is completely
destroyed howdy comma a man of your now
you can see the state of it it is
devastating the way they are farming
this land now where are the hazard
people going to leave a suburban info
chromium turtle when I was a child all
of this were thick forests there were
lots of animals and this area was
especially good for collecting honey it
hurts my soul to see it now to stop the
destruction it is now illegal to cut
down trees on HUDs erlend and where the
patrols find damage they can arrest or
reports the offenders who will face a
fine the project is funded by the global
carbon credit scheme where businesses
offset their emissions by contributing
money to projects that reduce carbon the
villages are given payments twice a year
of thousands of dollars and the patrols
also work with other tribes in the area
to voice their concerns about the
environment
there are now just under 1,000 heads of
people left in this area thought to be
among the last hunter-gatherers in the
world this everything you can see below
me here is the land of the hazard people
this is where we live this is where we
get our meat and our honey this is what
we call home